we are learning that a third American
has mysteriously died at a hotel in the
Dominican Republic a Pennsylvania woman
was reported dead last month now that's
five days before a Maryland couple died
apparently under very similar
circumstances CTM lead national
correspondent David Wagner was here with
more on this story this was very
disturbing and the more you hear the
worse it sounds do you think the deaths
are connected to authorities think that
we don't know for sure Gil but it's
interesting that both the State
Department and the FBI are looking into
it right that's very telling so you had
the Pennsylvania woman's family that
says she died from the same lung
condition as the Maryland couple but we
don't yet know how they died 41 year old
Miranda sho Horner was found dead at the
Gran Bahia Principe Hotel on May 25th
she was celebrating her ninth wedding
anniversary with her husband the family
says show Werner collapsed and died
shortly after she had a drink at the
hotel the US State Department says five
days before that show coroner died
Edward Holmes and Cynthia day from
Maryland were found dead in their hotel
room at the same hotel an autopsy found
the Maryland couple had respiratory
failure and a pulmonary edema that's a
condition caused by excess fluid in the
lungs
now hotel staff members say they found
the couple in their room and they were
unresponsive at a time there were no
signs of violence relatives say all
three Americans were healthy at the time
they died we should tell you we reached
out to the hotel but as of this morning
have not yet heard back thank you very
much David appreciate it